Independence is one of the
central concepts of
probability theory, because it
allows us to build large
models from simpler ones.
How should we define
independence in
the continuous case?
Our guide comes from the
discrete definition.
By analogy with the discrete
case, we will say that two
jointly continuous random
variables are independent if
the joint PDF is equal to the
product of the marginal PDFs.
We can now compare with the
multiplication rule, which is
always true as long as the
density of Y is positive.
So this is always true.
In the case of independence,
this is true.
So in the case of independence,
we must have
that this term is equal to that
term, at least whenever
this quantity--
the marginal of Y--
is positive.
So to restate it, independence
is equivalent to having the
conditional, given Y, be the
same as the unconditional PDF
of X. And this has to be true
whenever Y has a positive
density so that this quantity
is well defined, and it also
has to be true for all xs.
Now, what does this
really mean?
The conditional PDF, as we have
discussed, in terms of
pictures, is a slice
of the joint PDF.
Therefore, independence is the
same as requiring that all of
the slices of the joint have the
same shape, and it is the
shape of the marginal PDF.
For a more intuitive
interpretation, no matter what
value of Y you observe,
the distribution
of X does not change.
In this sense, Y does not convey
any information about
X. Notice also that this
definition is symmetric as far
as X and Y are concerned.
So by symmetry, when we have
independence, it also means
that X does not convey any
information about Y, and that
the conditional density of Y,
given X, has to be the same as
the unconditional
density of Y.
We can also define independence
of multiple
random variables.
The definition is
the obvious one.
The joint PDF of all the random
variables involved must
be equal to the product
of the marginal PDFs.
Intuitively, what that means is
that knowing the values of
some of the random variables
does not affect our beliefs
about the remaining
random variables.
Finally, let us note some
consequences of independence,
which are identical to the
corresponding properties that
we had in the discrete case,
and the proofs are also
exactly the same.
So the expectation of the
product of independent random
variables is the product of the
expectations, the variance
of the sum of independent random
variables is the sum of
the variances, and functions
of independent random
variables are also independent,
which, in
particular, implies, using the
previous rule, that the
expected value of a product of
this kind is going to be the
product of these expectations.
So independence of continuous
random variables is pretty
much the same as independence
of discrete random variables
as far as mathematics are
concerned, and the intuitive
content of the independence
assumption is the same as in
the discrete case.
One random variable does
not provide any
information about the other.